this is your personality right here this
is the expression
of your personality you gotta take care
of it
[Music]
so hi i'm pharrell williams in today's
episode we're gonna be taking
questions from the gq viewers the first
question from the audience
is what are your skin care essentials my
skin care essentials
are pretty much three steps it's always
making sure like you have a good
cleanser
always making sure that you have like a
really
good exfoliator and a great moisturizer
this is
the rice powder cleanser so a couple
shakes
a little bit of water
rub it together then you get like this
foamy sensation
i'm like going in circular motions and
i'm always going upward because
naomi would always tell me never go
downward you know a couple shakes of the
powder in my palm and then like with
water
when you mix it together you get like
this foamy sensation and sensation lets
you know
that not only does it work but it just
it's real some people don't like to uh
use a cloth but i do people are always
saying you know
skin care is like for for women and skin
health
is for women but you know it's for
people the next step
is our lotus enzyme exfoliators and i'm
always talking about
like exfoliating like a madman when they
ask me oh what do you do like that's the
number one thing
it's like removing the dead layers of
skin and the lotus enzyme
it rejuvenates the skin it gets rid of
the dead skin
and kind of like you know allows the new
skin to come to life under
uh what was there so yeah
that works
hey this right here just so you
understand this is called a t-zone
and when you put this on for sure you
feel it
the sensation is amazing there's the aha
glycolic acid in there so
that starts to work immediately you
immediately get that sensation that like
it's like getting below the layers of uh
skin
and i also put it in my eyebrows too and
again i use a face cloth
you see that glowing and i ain't even
put on any kind of moisture nothing
but look you feel me like
smooth and everybody's like oh your skin
your skin your skin as you can see
i have freckles in my face i have spots
in my face
but my but my skin itself feels
amazing this is our third step our
humidifying cream
now technically it's a moisturizer but
we own that term humidifying cream
because
i was so insistent with the terminology
humidifying this is like a
pea size right it's important to
moisturize because you want to lock in
the moisture you know rubbing it in is
super important
just getting it in there again i have it
in my eyebrows
everywhere popping
yeah how does your skin care routine
differ from morning to night
and what is your night routine so my
morning routine
and my night routine are very similar
the only difference is that i use a
vitamin c serum let me just give some
love to this instant
project and i use this just because i
feel like it locks in moisture
put this right here t-zone
and over the eyes
and under the eyes your skin is a result
the way your skin looks the result of
like what you're doing what's your
routine
how much time are you putting into it
the other thing that i use in the
daytime
not as much i'm supposed to this is
something that my wife comes down on me
about and this
is something that you know dr elena
comes down on me about which is
spf it's like super important so the
other thing that i didn't mention was
like
the the lip balm which is a good thing
too your lips cannot be dry
but this is like a lip balm that you can
use
the next question from our audience and
viewers is they're a single parent and
what should they
what should they teach their son about
skin care teach your son that skin care
and skin health
is not a gender specific thing it's a
human
hygienic and considerate courteous thing
you want to take care of your skin your
body is one thing
and your face is another i struggle with
drinking enough water
in a day any advice and how much water
do you drink in a day
so truth be told all i drink is water i
drink this water called flow
and then there's this um sparkling water
that's flavored called waterloo
and i'm just telling you do
not try it because stopping
is a problem the other thing too
is taking baths being submerged in water
is really good for your skin
i i recommend like epsom salt bath 20 to
30 minutes
you sweat out the toxins and then as
you're getting out
when your body is cooling down your fit
your pores just closed and your face
looks like
porcelain who taught you about self-care
growing up and how was yours
how has your self-care routine evolved
my dad just always prided himself on
smelling good
in terms of my mom my mom used to just
use like noxzema
that was like really the only thing
that she really used i would say my
self-care developed when i met elena
jones
when i met my dermatologist she was the
one that made me start to
you know to think about things
differently it was more about what those
products did
than it was the brands so that is kind
of like where i developed my
like understanding that this was a
necessity very grateful for this
opportunity
for the the space and time within
this gq installment it's 2020
and we've come a long way and i know
there's a lot of crazy
out there right now crazy but we got to
remember that we're in control
of our destiny and no matter how crazy
this is god is the greatest
i'm definitely going to keep pushing i
want you to keep pushing and remember
that gratitude is the attitude
so thank you